many children
have no food to eat and these children
are starving for education
it is alarming
that 57 million children
are deprived of education they cannot go
to school
this must shake our conscious
girls have been a target of sexual
violence and abuse
and they are only limited to the four
boundaries of their houses
there is no freedom
but still
there is hope
i am hopeful
the european
parliament will look beyond europe
to the suffering countries
where people are still deprived of their
basic rights
the powerful
country
shall not be judged
by counting its soldiers and navy
but rather we must see
which country has the highest literacy
rate which country has more educated
people which country has provided the
basic rights to its citizens
[Applause]
a country
with talented
skillful
and educated people
is the real super power not the country
with tons of soldiers and weapons
i'm hopeful
that through our unity and determination
we can achieve our goals
and help those 57 million children
who are waiting for
us and these children
they do not want
an iphone an xbox a playstation or
chocolates
they just want
a book
and a pen
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
you